it's time for screen junkies boobie buds
what's going on you guys all new movie
fights were doing it that's right I'm
your host Hal Rudnick and we've got an
exciting game we've got exciting
combatants and a whole new way to play
the game so FYI we have three judges now
deciding each round isn't that exciting
just our three yeah that's three more
than we used to
that's bananas I think that's really
cool yeah um it's a little different
around here and guess what we kind of
like it um we're having fun and deciding
each round like I said it's going to be
three judges and first you know me I'm
Hal Rudnick I am one of the judges but
we have a couple other ones you know him
you'll love them he's the man with the
facts fact-checking everything that's
said and judging rounds Dan Merle high
panic I went into memory muscle memory
and I was like where are my headphones
new mic here I'm mobile I got the the
facts are the important things how I
will be judging today's contestants
based on the facts based on proper
debate structure all the boring stuff
that nobody likes one of them as my vote
for who wins each round you know if it's
uh if there's one thing you've always
been good at its computing and
understanding boring stuff that no one
likes that's true that's very much true
thank you for holding it down over there
Dan Moreau and on the social medias our
social media ambassador
Roxy Stryker great to see you thanks for
having me I am the voice of the people
today so I don't have the vote for
myself I have the vote for you you don't
get a vote and you don't get a vote I'm
really into Oprah this week so here's
how it works guys you're gonna want to
vote on the iCard it's in the upper
right-hand corner of your YouTube screen
so cast your vote there I will be the
voice of the people if you have any
questions on how to use the iCard thanks
to Ryan it is in the description below
so check that out awesome thanks Roxy
and you couldn't have movie fights
without a couple of come
patents doing battle in this realm first
let's welcome you know him you love him
he's one of the writers of honest
trailers and gesto of a friend to us all
Joestar thank you I'm very excited to be
here I am nervous because I heard the
show is completely different so we are
still spending several rounds talking
about movies and then being judged and
then someone wins yeah but Joe you're
standing Oh Joe um the internet wants to
know do you think your legs can handle
standing for almost an hour
I've squatted for four hours today to
prepare for this dude you've been doing
some sick reps on Joestar never skips
like day no um and he will be facing on
the field of battle she's one of the
hosts of the tights and fights podcast
and a good friend of the family Daniel
Radford no work on that no that's not no
that was good you stole mine but it's
done that I originated but okay cool
cool short they will be fighting like
two little kitty cats today this might
be the most adorable movie fights ever
okay so again it there a couple of
changes we're gonna have three rounds
okay and then after that we're going to
jump into a four question speed round so
regardless of the score after the the
three regular rounds there's always a
chance to come back in that dangerous
speed round it's full of money
these uh folks Dan and Roxy will cast
votes first and then I will break any
ties and you guys I think that's about
it any questions Internet okay good um
Joe are you ready I'm prepared how
Rudnik Danielle you feeling it I'm
feeling it hell yeah JT e roll that
montage
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
yes sick montage JT okay let's jump into
the first question of movie fights do it
man it's a biggie what was the best
movie of 2017 small question yeah best
movie of 2017 and we're gonna start with
Joestar cool yeah guys look there's only
one movie that was big enough perfect
enough well loved enough to be
considered the best movie of 2017 that
movie was Dunkirk that's not true
I'm not gonna argue Dunkirk I just like
saying that cuz it gets a rise out of
the kids it's a perfectly fine movie but
not the best movie of 2017 the best
movie of 2017 was the big sick the big
sick wonderful movie first of all let's
really realize that the big sick
actually came out in 2017 why does 2017
feel like it was 200 years long the big
sick now feels like a ten year old movie
but it came out to behave 2017 it was
the leader of the pack when it came out
I still think it is the leader of the
pack now this was such a wonderful movie
it came out of nowhere and I think when
you're sort of considering the total
package of what makes a best movie
you've got to consider things like that
this movie came out of left field it had
so many wonderful surprises you know who
would have thought that Kumail Nanjiani
the who most of the public might have
known as like the third guy on Team
Hardwick you know like who knew that he
was an amazing leading man and this
movie gave us Kumail Nanjiani the
incredible leading man
it gave us easily Ray Romano's greatest
performance I mean I am a fan of
everyone loves Raymond but I mean his
role as Terry blows it out of the water
it was such a cool story even for
Michael Showalter it doesn't get
discussed as often but Michael Showalter
showed such a deft hand at subtle
rom-com after just cutting his teeth in
the state and Stella and wet hot
American summer and then you know even
the Baxter which was his movie where he
tried to call
the tropes of a rom-com just kind of
falling flat on his face it was so cool
to see Michael Showalter step up and
show that he's the MIT the man has
skills with a Z instead of an S all of
these things to me anchored by an
incredible performance by Holly Hunter
just makes the big sick the total
package for me
amazing screenplay by Emma Levy Gordon
best movie of 2017 all right opening
salvo from Joestar haha
Danielle Radford please talk to us okay
so a great movie but for me my best
movie of 2017 which I also couldn't
believe came out this year this has been
a long year was get out for me get out
is the perfect example of genre movies
doing what genre movies do best which is
being able to comment on things that are
happening around us while also still
being in this case as a horror movie
really incredibly genuinely terrifying
this was Jordan peels coming out party
it is the movie that everyone knew him
from key and Peele
they knew that he was very funny and
delightful and can do great sketches
this was the movie that made it so he
would be able to do you know something
involving the Twilight Zone or other
kind of genre things this is the movie
that made people begin to take Jordan
Peele seriously as a director and as a
writer these performances were also
amazing both Bradley Whitford and
Catherine Keener managed to make me hate
them and they're two of my favorite
people ever but now from now on every
time I see Catherine Keener and at E I'm
just going to leave the I can't be there
anymore it's scary and I hate it it was
also the coming-out party for a low rel
who is the littlest of the rels he's
clearly the smallest that's why they
call him that and this was also a movie
where he was someone who had been doing
a lot of work he's been around forever
but most people didn't really appreciate
what he could bring to a role comedic
Lee until get out in which he stole
every single scene that he was in and
those are just the people who aren't the
main character
you have Daniel Kahlua and Allison
Williams again Allison Williams being
absolutely positively terrifying and
eating Froot Loops like a weirdo which
is nothing but points for her
performance because that's really
disgusting and she sold it very well
again it's one of the movies that I feel
like has managed to bring back horror
because a lot of people were very
enthusiastic about horror movies after
get out came out you start hearing a lot
of people talking about movies that
maybe wouldn't have gotten as much press
or as much push from studios now
suddenly getting pushed because it
almost feels like this is a movie that
has brought the horror genre back from
kind of a very you know greed Gore for
Gore sake I'm gonna say Gore like eight
more times really gory Al Gore Oh
gore verbinski it was just it was a very
it was a genre that had kind of slid
into being very voyeuristic and again it
brought it back into doing what genre
and science fiction and what those kind
of movies do best we'll just talk about
what's happening in the world around us
great you unpacked a lot about get out
you guys let's fight it out let's fight
now here's what I like about these two
movies we're both sort of coming at why
they're real good from the same angle
and both of these movies are really good
so this is really I think just a who can
shout about why there's better more
fight because both of these movies are
just really fantastic I I do think they
are both coming out parties in a lot of
ways Kumail Emily B Gordon you know like
I said even Ray Romano in a way like I
didn't know right had that in them this
movie also I think revived the rom-com
in a lot of ways because we we perceive
the rom-com as this like sappy obnoxious
new york is basically a character you
guys sort of like garbage genre that you
might watch on a plane if you've run out
of movies to watch on a plane and it
took that and it gave it a really nice
indie feel without and I mean that in a
positive way I think sometimes people
like can use Indy as a dig but I mean
that in a very positive way it all
took the genre and this might hit more
to home for the three of us than it
might people watching it took the genre
of what can me and my comedian friends
write really to task because most things
currently about being a comic and being
a performer our plays on being my wacky
roommates webseries or even just man
this job sure is hard and only focusing
like on the job of it my mind just
blanked it wouldn't be a thing that I'm
on if I if it didn't but I
keegan-michael Keys improv movie don't
don't think twice don't think twice
thank you I was just gonna make it a UCB
plug and that's it don't think we're a
fine movie but got way too caught up on
the mechanics and politics of comedy
whereas this movie focused so strongly
on the costs a little bit of that
pursuit and how speed bumps in your life
can affect them and vice versa and I
just thought that was so visceral and
such an interesting take that you know
it was it was never something that
really stuck with me in this movie is
that through kumail's arc it's never a
question of I gotta stop pursuing the
thing which is just because my life took
a bit of a left turn it's it's no you
you take that left turn and and you keep
you embrace it and you keep running with
it because that's that's what getting
older is and that that's what you know
growing up is a lot and the movie didn't
harp on that a whole lot but it's
something that I that I took away from
it without it being preachy which I
really really enjoyed and now I'll let
you speak no one in this movie ate Froot
Loops weird
I do give that as a point I do concede
the Froot Loops point okay he conceives
the Froot Loops point Danielle I'm a
breakfast gentleman see if anything as
much as I'll and the big stick is a
great movie as much as I enjoyed that
the parts about him being a comedian I
as a comic who's been doing this for way
too long I am real done with us talking
about ourselves
and how hard coming isn't comedy so hard
and aren't our friends so funny and he
did come and obviously one of the big
the movie was more about what was
happening with Emily but there is still
that sticking point of man can I get a
comedian to just once right something
that isn't about how hard it is to be a
comedian which whereas with Jordan Peele
and with get out Jordan Peele is also a
comedian
um studied at UCB all of those things
and yet he made a movie that is both
funny and is something that is about
more than himself it is inspired by the
idea that he was going to go meet his
new lady's parents and was kind of
terrified but ultimately Camille's story
hits you because it is real and that is
that's a great point for well in movie
but it's also like I feel like it's a
lot easier to write about things that
actually happened to you than to write
about something that is more of just a
like your worst nightmare I don't know
because you know Kumail and Emily V
Gordon themselves have have talked about
how hard it was to just rehash that that
that period of their life so it seemed
like it was really difficult something
another parallel I find between these
movies that's very interesting is that
they both talk about race and how it
plays into relationships what I like
about the big SiC is it gave me a POV
that I have really like never heard a
lot about or thought a lot about and
that is kumail's families view against
dating a white person like there's
plenty of movies where like a white guy
might you know might date someone of
another race and their wife Pam was like
oh isn't this interesting but I've never
seen you know a scene like the the
dinner scenes with his family where
they're just like it's not he's not even
able to discuss it with them because
they're busy like setting them up with
that box of headshots and I just think
that's so so interesting it's so
fascinating to watch jungle fever
because they do talk about that's not
the first time you've said that to me to
be completely fair and and I get it I
totally get it if I have one dig against
get out is that it is a very well shot
very well retooled step
wives whereas I felt like the big stick
because it was from the heart Phil feels
a lot more original and and unexpected
at times once I got it yeah thoughts on
that um I I think that it's hard for me
to consider something to be incredibly
original when it is just pulling
literally like a diary chapter from
someone's life and I do understand how
hard it can be to rehash some of the
more painful things that have happened
to you but I think it is way harder to
be able to think of something like the
sunken place which is something I've
also never seen in movies before and
that twist of we didn't quite know what
was happening with the characters a lot
of us thought that it was going to be
the sunken place and the hypnosis and so
when they brought out brain transplants
they found a way to twist us that we
were not expecting and I feel like that
takes a lot more creativity than I'm a
comedian and my wife almost died so I'm
writing a movie about how I'm a comedian
and my wife almost died
so both of you touched on reasons why
your film is a great film Oh for a film
to be considered the best film I think
it has to transcend so many of the other
movies that year so I want each of you
to tell me why your film is transcendent
and how it affects how it has an impact
on the social conversation because each
film definitely had some social
components sure well let's start with
Jeff you know I don't really think
either of these films had a whole lot of
social care really we're really digging
I don't like talking politics in my
movies and these two movies were
completely devoid of them at all
I mean Kumail and Emily's relationship
is social you know commentary in of
itself the dynamics of that relationship
his decision to sort of dig in and stay
and even race aside the the social
commentary between Beth and Terry that
admission this is one of my favorite
scenes I have a few scenes in this movie
that just haven't left me since I've
since I watched it that the scene where
he is bunked up in kumail's gross oil
bedroom and admits that he had
pher with his wife and then watching
that scene play out very subtly when
they're all having wine and pizza
together is is another just fascinating
just social commentary on like we
screwed up we hit a we hit our own speed
bump just like you guys in your
relationship are hitting your left turn
and and how does that play out how do we
deal with it and the movie just does it
so well without preaching and without
being like hey did you see the point
did you see the point of the movie you
know in a way that I just thought was
just very fun and and just refreshing
okay Daniel how is get out a
transcendent film how does it impact the
social conversation well what was
interesting to me about get out is that
when you initially watch it it feels
like it's gonna be very straightforward
like a man goes to a town where all the
black folks are being turned into slaves
and then the twist of that which was the
twist I was talking about earlier is
that they're not being turned into
slaves what we haven't initially
interpreted from the media and from what
the movie what we thought that the
trailers and things were saying was that
it was going to be about the
commodification of black bodies and it
still was but it was more about like the
commodification of black culture and it
touched on and cultural appropriation is
something that we'd talk about it's part
of like the cultural conversation now
and it touched on it in such a literal
way that it was hilarious and it made
that particular conversation which can
be a really rough one to have and people
get really passionate people get really
angry on all sides it's really hard to
argue with how hilarious it is to watch
these folks in these really bad wigs who
are these older white people who are
like oh no I definitely for sure want to
be like a black dude that can just run
again sure that's like that and that's a
very powerful kind of image in and of
itself and I think that that was one of
the most powerful conversations that
came out of it because again like the
cultural appropriation argument it can
get very passionate with a lot of people
saying well what's the difference
between appropriation and appreciation
and there's definitely a difference and
there's definitely something to be said
for cultural sharing but in this case it
was just like I'm gonna put my brain in
your body
hashtag gotta put my brain in your body
radio gotcha now you've both spoken
pretty highly of the other persons film
I wouldn't shove it pretend like you're
like just a petulant child a kid with a
bad attitude and I just really tell us
what's wrong why your movies better than
the other movie Danielle tell us why
your movie so much better than stupid
big sick love is stupid and she lived
and it would have been like so much more
deep if she would have like died at the
end
oh my god like he like learned such a
lesson I don't know man I got dumped
last year so I'll just pretend like I'm
real bitter her big sick dumb and
shouldn't survive and man it's a really
good movie um can you uh can you zing
Danielle on get out can you tell us why
yours is so much better than get out the
only like the only thing I can I can
really construct is that he'll cut his
teeth you know doing doing his sketch
show which was so heavily leaning into
here's a genre here here's how we skewer
it you know here's horror here's how I
can spin it here's action here I could
here's how I can spin here's
post-apocalypse here's how I can spin it
and he kind of did that again well you
know on the big screen and did it very
well but in a way it was it was if if
you were a big fan of key and Peele it
was it was what you expected I think
from from a Jordan Peele movie yeah and
Camille did a great job of playing a
dude married to a woman who was what I
love fest this first round is for all
the movies involved can we talk about
Dunkirk okay Joe any final thoughts you
know that's it all right
[Laughter]
um both of these movies are obviously
hold a very high esteem but I will say
due to the genre and the fantasy
elements I think that that puts get out
ahead of his stupid movie with people in
love
great then I steal any uh no I was just
uh look man Holly Hunter at the height
of her powers I think you know one of
the one of
best scenes of 2017 was Holly Hunter
circling her husband when they're having
an argument in that waiting room and
she's like a lion it was it's one of
those moments where you pause and you're
just like yeah she's a good actor it was
just great and that scene is my final
thought time okay great Dan talked to us
well it's a matter of opinion so there's
not a whole lot of facts they are both
correct that they both two movies this
is rare two movies that came out in the
earlier first half of the year get big
secrets released on June 23rd and
limited release get out was released all
the way back to February almost a year
ago so I had to go kind of buy their
arguments looking at kind of back and
forth I think that Joe got the edge as
far as bringing the genre back I think
some of Danielle's arguments over
generalized a little bit of what the
horror genre become and I thought that
Joe made some points about the romantic
comedy genre itself however there were
some things that I thought Danielle did
a little bit better on Joe you ceded the
critical fruit loops point never a good
idea but I also think what kind of won
me over and even the closing arguments
kind of cemented it to me was that Joe
kept going back to specific scenes and
her in his movie that he thought were
really good and I thought that Danielle
did a better job of showing how the
movie itself subverted expectations I
think that she was a little bit stronger
on the social question and I think that
Joe kind of got dinged a little bit by
bringing up the dinner scene and
Danielle was able to counter that so if
I'm just going point counterpoint who
made the stronger argument I'm gonna
have to go with Danielle on this one
boom there you go one Oh Danielle Roxy
talk to us what's going on social media
all right well they did wish that
Dunkirk had stuck from one of the two of
you there was a lot of Dunkirk lovin
here for your movies at some point were
called overrated by model people and
underrated also baby driver disaster
artist Wind River sweep of water mother
called me by your name last Jedi which
got a lot of other meat okay and a lot
of hate Logan Blade Runner three
billboards we even had a pitch from
lobster for get out 2049
so that sounds like an interesting movie
pitch to have good and I would watch the
crappy blur also by the way loving this
new format so congratulations you guys
up there I have to say this is not even
a close one
this is a landslide victory slam-dunk
get out with 68% Wow okay Daniel rather
you take the first point thank you all
right who are the kisses to me for me oh
then we're very we're doing this Jeannie
Olli yes this is not a sportsmanship
going on friendly scrimmage this is a
pickup game of Dan fights a bad check
question Oh Joe called Ray Romano show
everyone loves Raymond is it everybody
everybody loves everybody loves right
that was critical to the argument had
been 50/50 that would have been the
deciding factor in favor of Danielle but
I'm clearly a faux mono fan yes great
let's move on to round two one Oh
Danielle Radford okay so we s1 was the
best what was the worst movie of 2017
and Danielle we're gonna start with you
for me this it didn't even feel like a
contest the worst movie of 2017 was a
book of Henry I'd like it's book if
Henry was one of those movies that was
so bad that remember Colin Trevorrow at
one point was handed the keys to every
Kingdom every movie Kingdom and then
after book of Henry everyone was like
hey can we get those keys back haha just
kidding you know what it's fine we'll
just go ahead and change the locks don't
come in tomorrow
book of Henry was it was a movie you
know the the script itself was written
about 20 years ago and it feels it and
it's a movie that's supposed to be this
sweet story about a little boy who from
beyond the grave to just his mom had a
[ __ ] kill somebody who's our first
f-bomb
Tata's mom like here's how you
straight-up murder and it's supposed to
be a sweet movie about saving a younger
woman that he are a woman that he had a
crush on but it doesn't land because it
comes off very saccharine the writing is
not great and the central premise of the
movie which is I'm gonna trust you know
I'm I'm a woman child who doesn't do
anything in a write you know who doesn't
do any of the adult things around the
house I always trusted that to my genius
boy and so because that boy is a genius
even though he's 11 and super dead I'm
still gonna let him teach me how to
murder well when you put it that way all
right
opening salvo from Danielle Joestar what
do you got I mean first of all I just
want to say that I think it's very
commendable to try to make a sweet sweet
version of the good son where Macaulay
Culkin is a ghost I think that's you
know an important challenge to take on I
think it was important to cinema this
year I want to talk about a movie called
bright cuz it was the worst movie of
you guys this movie was a failure on
absolutely every level first of all it
is a hard movie to argue cuz no one has
actually seen the movie bright because
this movie was shot so dark and so muddy
you did not actually see anything in
this movie I know I sat in front of
Netflix and I could hear Will Smith's
voice but most of the time I I don't
know it was it felt like I was watching
a butt cam that a guy had shot that
Spencer had downloaded it for us to
write an honest trailer or something
look guys this was look what could go
wrong but cam you know but cam sure okay
we're a guy in the movie theater sits on
his butt it looks so bad looks like but
it's a butt cam gotcha hashtag butt cam
guys from the director of a classic
superhero film Suicide Squad the writer
of Victor Frankenstein an American ultra
a racism allegory by those two white
guys what could go wrong what girl
everything went wrong I mean from the
opening scene the the fairy lives don't
matter line you're already getting
you're already a Ligurian bad there's
there's zero sense of tension through
this movie any goodwill that I think
David Ayer scored for like end of watch
is gone like after watching bright I no
longer feel like Suicide Squad was the
studio's fault macaws that I walked out
and I was like I liked David Ayer sure
and then everyone's like well the studio
really stepped in heavily and I was like
thank God David Ayer still a genius and
then I watched bright from Netflix which
is famous for giving people their their
creative control and geniuses these two
gentlemen were not in this thing it's
it's hugely tone-deaf it takes it tries
to be this gritty street-level LA crime
movie but anytime there's like an
important decision or important moment
they ruin it with slo-mo or or bullet
time or a song or something like that is
it's completely tone-deaf
alright let's mix it up you guys let's
do it mix it up okay one thing I will
say about Bryant is that I know that it
shot very dark but bright is a movie
that many people call bright Danielle
it's called bright so bright in stark
it's dark what's the deal many people
delighted and hate watching that movie
that was a very it's a very hate
watchable movie in fact so much it again
didn't get a sequel there is never going
to be a book of Henry to book harder as
much you don't know that the only thing
you don't know that and bright to was
greenlit before bright even came out
once it came out they immediately
ejected max landis from writing duties
because it's a train wreck and David
Ayer still connected to it for now which
i think is a bad decision book of henry
is is almost fun to watch in its earnest
absurdity like book of henry from scene
to scene i'm like look at the boy with
the steampunk goggles and
and the kanji leatherhead with just walk
around with this plunger like that's a
ridiculous ridiculous movie whereas
Brite was such a slog Bryant had like
four different endings it wouldn't end
and by the end of it there's nothing
more unfun than a movie where I am
literally shouting and when or cough
went back into that burning building to
save Will Smith I was just like just
burned to death I don't I don't care and
then and then they turn it all of a
sudden into men and black with like an
extended comedy riff between the two of
them with elf fed and it's just it's
such a departure and you're just like
just and I want this to stop
I want to isn't the first movie
involving orcs that wouldn't stop and
needed to I loved drinks but that also
had a can't stop won't stop being what's
up with the orcs as clumsy as a racism
allegory as that was I don't give this
bad racism allegory of past Daniel
Radford I'm not um I'm not but I will
say that it is I applaud risk even when
it results in failure
Bunker's kuku Henry is a Lifetime movie
directed by a multimillion like dollar
making person like book of Henry could
have been on ABC and it would have been
like special movie of the week starring
a down-on-her-luck
Halle Berry because those are great
those are the best Christmas movies
those all those movies are so good I'm
not comparing in the same way in the
same way that mother was clearly written
over three days and he's owned that it's
it was written over three days this
movie this movie was expanded from a
pitch that was thought up on the way to
Century City pitched for ten minutes in
a room and sold and that's how it feels
it is so shallow this world is so
shallow it's just it's just let me show
you some fifth grade Trapper Keepers and
I will prove you differently both of you
describe the other person's movie as a
fun hate watch or you could get some
enjoyment out of watching that person's
movie for the wrong reasons
tell us
your film tell us why the other person's
film succeeds as a fun hate watch
therefore not making it the worst movie
or cop and Will Smith working through
racism all of a sudden now black folks
are racist oh I'm sorry
orcs wearing chains and in gangs we
haven't touched that because I want to
get in back okay fun there's some fun
going on that Daniel is throwing at us
why is book of Henry more of a fun hey
one thing that's not fun because it
works are black people than black people
in Mexican can't be the same black
people in Mexican that they are in this
fantasy world otherwise they're all this
here's why Jo just had an aneurysm
here's why this is why I watched book of
Henry yeah because Dan Morel went to a
screener of book of Henry yes and we'll
put this on Dan because he came into the
room and just described this thing like
he had seen a ghost and like the ghost
had dumped water on him and then tweaked
his nipples and run away like that's how
it just perplexed he was by what he had
just seen and and that is what book of
Henry is book of Henry is you want to
see a dead body and you show people a
book of Henry they won't you won't
forget the night that everyone got
together and watched book of Henry it's
it's so much closer to Tommy Wiseau's of
the room than brightest story actually
the bright could have been a better hate
watches if there would have been a music
video right in the middle right to you
guys
writer and broken so right now I'm gonna
throw a little task at each of you you
know in a movie like a crazy old man
runs into a city hall meeting and he's
like no Soylent Green is people
and he gives like a big warning to
everybody I want you to give a crazy
warning to everyone out there why your
film is the worst goddamn film of 2017
this has to be a rant that this has to
be energized look into that camera
Danielle you're going first why the hell
is this movie so bad and to be avoided
they made me homie watts act like she
was going to murder a grown man because
her Kate was too smart and he was going
to murder the grown man and left her
instructions
look I'm just saying like if your child
is dying maybe you should have point
them towards something a little more
constructive than just murdering people
like why couldn't he have used that and
written a
beautiful note about how much he loved
thee like his life and he loved his mom
if I was his mom and my kids dying in at
the end of his life it's like oh no it's
not so much about how I loved you and I
appreciated the hard work and care that
went in to 11 years of you letting me
raise your raise myself and so much as
here's an instruction manual about how
to kill and get away with it this I was
a psychopath and maybe you should have
died Joe
give us a rant gather round [ __ ] and
let me tell you the tale of a movie that
runs out of gas because the writer ran
out of monster energy drink before we
got to the third act for one thing guys
Joe Rogan exists which means the man
show existed in this movie were the lady
elves jumping on trampolines like what
was the man show if this is a junior
token world and who is that Corolla in
the bright first I don't know why does
the N word exist does that mean that
after talking just America just did its
normal like trajectory it makes
absolutely no sense how are these things
unaffected how is Snoop Dogg a famous
rapper is the NWA all orcs like I don't
understand humans are like the middle
class so like you're handling this from
how did the NWA fur guys it wouldn't be
called elf town if elves are 1% the 1%
doesn't call things rich town they just
call it Beverly Hills okay you know what
you're dropping all these facts ever
getting me more and more curious about
bright okay
any thoughts Danielle this is your final
thought he's acting like I'm not gonna
watch orcs with attitude like I don't
download that mix tape right no coming
straight out of middle-earth it would
still just be Compton oh my god and then
they can actually do it right out of
Compton but it's all just orcs look at
what you just did to me now I want to
make that movie someone pay me to write
straight out of Compton but it's works
okay final thoughts Joe final thoughts
how do you make wolf Will Ferrell how do
you make Will Smith unlikable it's
impossible second final thought if
you're if you're going to put the words
trigger warning entertainment at the
beginning of your movie you better
deliver and you didn't deliver look this
was written with the expectations that
it would be the new Star Wars and it was
this was a terrible movie it proved the
studio interference was not to blame
with Suicide Squad and if you can't tell
this story better than Zootopia told it
why bother
time alright Wow a bad movie stand talk
to us well yeah I mean the first half of
this entire round was really them
convincing people why they should
immediately go watch both of their media
it was very difficult for me to make a
judgement the second round is kind of
what did it a couple of personal notes
number one we do not use but cams in the
process of writing those trailers if we
did you would have had Justice League
two months ago
thank you secondly I did not go to a
screening of book in Henry a book of
attorney it was much much worse I paid
actual money to go see the book of his
movie oh oh it was a day it was book of
Henry all eyes on me and rough night
that was my well I didn't know at the
time and all professional button for
punishment exactly so it came down to
the second half for me and Joe Rogan is
the key to all this from Joe Rogan on I
thought Joe did an exceptional job
selling me on bright at why it was the
worst of the year so I have to give the
closer to Joe and the point to Joe boom
that's one for Joe Roxy
talk to us a lot of hate in the chat
right now in a good way for all
different movies like fifty shades
darker the emoji movie ya may watch this
but Nolan
Dean says The Mummy is the only movie
this year that actually made me want to
rip my eyeballs out so that's saying
something a lot of people voting for the
room don't think that counts yeah that
can be your vote but that's okay
Joshua poten says book of Henry might be
in the so bad it's actually good
commentary we ran into that a couple of
times
Natalia says what's bright is it a food
[Laughter]
what I will say is this was leaning very
very heavy one way until the fire came
out of Joe and once the fire came out
you flipped this around with 64% for
bright whoa Joe star lit it up and takes
the points we are deadlocked at 1:1 Wow
with Shrek a biopic in bright Joe if you
haven't written a stand-up riff about
bright you apart from my judging I do
agree the Alamo thing did bother me very
much watching bright like was it was it
like fairies at the Alamo like it was
the alo a thing with different people
it's kind of the same question like with
Planet of the Apes like why was there an
ape bruh ham link yes exactly dude we
just have this exact parallel world yeah
alright so we are locked up deadlocked
at 1:1 and let's go to the third
question hmm who was the best villain of
2017 best movie villain of 2017 Joe
we're gonna start with you let me calm
down a minute I think there's a few
things that set a really good villain
apart
one is that they think they're in the
right but even more than that they can
convince you that maybe they're a little
in the right like that's why magneto is
such a good villain like you know
magneto can drop an asteroid on the
planet or pull up a bridge like you did
in a bad one or kill Nazis or kill those
Nazis and or tear all the metal at a low
ghen bones and you're still like
okanagan were is coming from and the
villain that fit that bill for me this
year was the character of Tonya Harding
in AI Tonya and prepare for my uphill
battle on this round this movie opens
with with a single line that says that
it's based on
interviews that are wildly inconsistent
so right off the bat the filmmaker of
this faux documentary is telling you to
take all of this with a grain of salt
and then takes this woman who was a part
of a of a very very mean thing to do to
another figure skater and it allows her
to control her own narrative completely
not only to the point that you start to
question her involvement at all but to
the point that you're like who's the
real victim here and I think that's so
so brilliant because this is a character
that is giving interview and guiding the
narrative to camera she's aware of what
she's doing this character is aware that
this is her moment to sort of pull
everyone to her side and I think it
worked people people left this movie
going
hey maybe Nancy Kerrigan was mean and I
just think kissy fingers I think that's
absolutely brilliant okay Joe star taken
by Tonya Harding
Danielle who's your biggest villain in
2017 mmm my biggest villain of 2017 and
guys I swear I have seen more movies
then then just get out but my for me my
top villain was rose Armitage because
Rose more than anything in the same way
that you could argue that Tanya manages
to convince you that she is real and
that she's worth sympathy Rose convinces
you for most of the movie that she is a
good person who has her boyfriend's best
interests at heart
she's really into this relationship she
rejects a lot of maybe the more I'm
suburban and small-town uncaused
Napolitan as it might be looked at in
the view of the movie things about her
the way that she grew up and then in the
end you just find out that she is super
evil and she's so evil that it's not
just that she is involved in this brain
swapping thing she clearly takes
pleasure out of being involved with the
evil brain swapping because at one point
he main character Chris is looking
through pictures and he sees that Rose
has been used as essentially a honeypot
to collect all of the bodies that the
people in this town use for their evil
and you know that because she has
pictures of all of them that she keeps
almost as though they were treasured
mementos she clearly she played she
clearly gets off during get out on the
kind of power that she is able to wield
with her with her sweetness and with her
ability to draw people in and I like
that they do it in a way where it
doesn't come off like Oh her raw
sexuality is what's getting people know
it's how manipulative mm-hmm
that urban outfitters sweater is a
thirst trap no I agree with you all
right let's mix it up you guys here's
the genius of Tonya Harding in this
movie at the end of the in the third act
she she states sort of what the
characters after and what she wants she
says I had I was the most beloved or
well most known person in the country
after Bill Clinton I had to keep chasing
that spotlight and that's as she's going
into the women's boxing and this is the
characters chance to completely redefine
her narrative because she is not a
well-liked person I don't know if you
remember and one of the most brilliant
things about it was her delicate way she
was able to drop in moments of can we
talk a minute about Nancy Kerrigan and
and she she dropped in just enough to
for you to go
oh maybe Nancy Kerrigan is sort of a
stuck-up rich girl that I shouldn't have
been rooting for because of the system
but she doesn't go it's so much that
like your your [ __ ] alarm starts to
go off you know and she it's very
delicate she's been she's been planning
it's almost like she's been planning
this interview for ages and and you
leave going she's a hero and you know
what her ex-husband might not even be at
fault it's probably just that guy who
thought he was in international
espionage it's probably all his fault
and and this is why Tonya Harding I
think is a better villain than Rose a
because her perm is much cooler than
roses simple girl bangs
very fair but also she wins she wins
Rose rose loses in the end ultimately
she gets she got shot she done gets she
done gets killed
whereas Tonya Harding wins and she never
drops the facade once it's like it's
like each morning wins come back and I
think the Tonya Harding wins and she
does come off as more than sympathetic I
think that it's interesting that you
pick the exact narrative the exact
comparison I thought you were going to
which was magneto saying that you picked
that because what that does is that
allows for shades of grey and for me if
I'm talking about Best Villain I'm gonna
get a little a little you know if I'm
gonna talk about Best Villain I want
someone who is unrepentantly evil not
someone where there are possible shades
of grey and you are able to feel a kind
of sympathy for them yeah you know it's
there's obviously a lot to be said about
the fact that the real Tonya Harding now
gets to go to the Golden Globes but if
anything that shows that the movie did
such a great job and Gillespie and
Rogers did such a great job of painting
her as do you know this is not black and
white this is a this is a shades of grey
story and look how she you know grew up
when I've got things like the cycle of
abuse but I have that is then able to I
think that's scarier though in a way
because Rose roses reveal is I'm tying
you to the train tracks whereas Tonya
Harding her character in the in this
movie is is able to be much more
manipulative and she she never really
shows her her true colors oh maybe a
little at the end when she kind of winks
at you and really puts the exclamation
point on her I guys I was fine all along
where she's like I'm gonna keep getting
back up and like winks at you but to me
it almost strikes me as the usual
suspects
if Keyser söze doesn't start walking
normal I mean she pulls off the perfect
magic trick she she totally gets away
with it I think that that's necessarily
having to get punched in the face for
realsies is getting away with it because
there there is still the argument on
culturally about about Tonya and
obviously we have to separate character
Tanya from real-life Tanya
but there is still she know she is not
at the top of her game at the end of
this she is still you know she's
conducting these interviews but she
understands that she has to tell her
story in order for her story to get out
okay I'm gonna throw a curveball here so
there's a little bit of gray area
possibly in your villain your villain is
definitely just evil intentions from the
get-go all right what am i this might be
a terrible idea by the way you guys what
let's do it let's do it
okay but what am i doing this is
villains come from Disney movies so I
want you to imagine your villain is in a
Disney movie I want you to give us your
villain song just two lines just two
lines from your villains Disney song and
yes my terrible idea so we're gonna
start with you it's I will break up your
need or at least have my husband do it
for me
great okay Danielle you navigated that
very well that was like a triple axel
triple axel okay final thoughts Joestar
final thoughts she really did she really
did I think you know it's it's that time
and I am I'm trying very hard to
separate this movie character cuz again
the the movie says I don't know man this
lady's probably full of it at the top of
the film but she gets away with it she
wins so much so that the cultural
conversation around the actual Tonya
Harding has now changed and I think that
that's uh that that's a sneaky sneaky
move Tony Hardy but Nancy Kerrigan
so wins and is also a winner whereas all
of the people who had their brains
scooped out and old people's brains put
in are not winners she is complicit with
a lot of murder and Nancy Kerrigan is uh
she got a lot to be bitter and upset
about but she's still super alive and
was super able to compete and was still
and still won medals afterwards so time
okay wow what a collision of two awful
women Dan Murrow yeah give us some
thoughts Wow
very difficult I'm gonna have to well
actually a little bit this is movie
fights trying to clean magneto pulled
the adamantium out of Wolverine skeleton
the comics not in the movies that's just
my job and I have to do it nicely done
Danvers
nicely done during not extinction agenda
when was that that was no it was during
we're going down the comic book rabbit
hole - Troy dam I believe and there's a
whole thing anyway that's beyond the
point what this came down to from an
objective standpoint here is who made
the more compelling argument is Joe's
compelling argument of Tonya Harding
being kind of the perpetrator of a
hoodwinking in the audience or
Danielle's argument about rose and and
obviously the awful things that she does
in that movie ultimately I'm not quite
sure if Joe won me over on the argument
that Tonya Harding was the villain in
the sense that she was a sly mastermind
it's kind of undermined by the fact that
the movie itself says that it's not
really sure which side of the story that
there is so there wasn't a definitive
winner for me in that scenario so I'm
gonna have to go with Danielle based on
her arguments one Oh Danielle
Roxy stride let me ask you a question
before you weigh in with the poll have
there been any dankmemes there have been
but mostly of like Trump and Logan Paul
and Harvey wines of 2017 okay
talk to us you know I just am a little
surprised that we're referring to Tonya
Harding and Nancy Kerrigan both as
winners and this
day one dude that was a lot of love for
kylo Ren Pennywise vulture Joker during
Lego Batman movie tonya harding's mom
mommy
Kingsman hella from Thor Richard
Strickland which is Michael Shannon's
character in the shape of water dam
everyone definitely agreed that
Steppenwolf was not the winner of this
round CGI but the winner this one back
and forth this was the closest one so
far but it did ultimately go to Rose
Danielle you get the point on this one
thank you
Danielle you take a 2-1 lead going into
the speed round where you murder me
before we get into the speed round I
want to give a shout out to our
community moderators on our YouTube
channel just keeping the conversation
going keeping the conversation positive
and we love and appreciate we have a
little round of applause for our YouTube
moderators thank you guys thank you so
much for holding it down and taking care
of the chats and the comments and all
that good stuff and if you want to sign
up to become a screen junkies YouTube
moderator
just head to sj+ comm slash community to
find out more you guys you ready to play
fast and furious yes it's time for the
speed round so a player needs a total of
four points between the main round and
the speed round combined to win the game
same rules apply as before okay it's a
nothing cuckoo crazy
the player who answers first gets 20
seconds to answer the second player also
gets 20 seconds then each player gets a
10 second rebuttal
okay that's how that works Danielle you
feeling it feeling it Joe in my veins
yes let's play some speed round question
one who should direct gambit now that
Gore Verbinski has dropped out
Ava Duvernay tick-tocking it I know I
just don't want I don't want a gambit
movie ooh you know I'll just say Jordan
Peele again Jordan Peele I'm gonna
continue going on this run and
pretending I have
okay so we have Ava Duvernay vs. Jordan
Peele Joe we heard from you first 20
seconds on the clock for Joe star the
gambit movie has just been on this shelf
for so long that I'm tired of it hearing
about it I'm just I'm not interested in
this movie at all the only thing that is
going to make me interested in game it
again is a crazy left-field director and
I feel like if it's the last person I
would expect to be like I want to write
Cajun trench or a direct Cajun trench
coat thief movie and that would that
would get me interested time okay 20
seconds Jordan Peele I got much the same
way I would like to I think combine the
sensibility of a gambit you really play
up his New Orleans miss you know what
said it during essence festival do it as
girls trip three and have Jordan feel
direct and then he also picks the
pockets of everybody while he is that
essence best living his best life and
learning happy times okay ten second
rebuttal I've got a number of words that
I haven't counted together for you Oprah
Winfrey as the leader of the Thieves
Guild the perfect foil for gambit and
Oprah's only gonna sign on a day the
signs on and so I want that game okay
OC cuz I was actually gonna cast Oprah
as a young storm because that is how her
Anton's gambit first meant so I was
gonna age down my Oprah and then he was
gonna meet her back when she was D aged
in the comic books and that's okay a
couple of plum rolls for Oprah dance
I respect the brett's of Danielle's
creative vision however
that produced a more realistic and
compelling case I'm gonna have to cast
my vote for Joseph
apparently he didn't Roxy a lot of love
in the chat for different all the people
you can name Plus LL Cool J and Tommy
Wiseau so the gambit movie I feel as if
both of you guys don't really want again
baby that hard the gambit movie that I
enjoyed more theoretically would have
been Jose Jill gets the plane for me Joe
that's great though cuz Tommy is from
New Orleans Tommy Wiseau directed gambit
movie but for now Joe star gets the
point for Ava Duvernay we are locked up
at 2-2 what a great moment in sports
[Laughter]
second question of the speed round who
would you rather be in a relationship
with the beast from Beauty and the Beast
or amphibian man from shape of water
amphibian man okay you get the beast
from Beauty and the Beast
hmm Danielle we heard from you first 20
seconds on the clock
dan you ready all right Danielle
whenever you've won I'm the best thing
about being in a relationship with the
amphibian man is that I could leave him
in his tube and just go away any time I
wanted to whereas the beast would keep
me captured inside his weird creepy home
with his weird singing everything I
don't want to be in a world where the
toilet roll might start suddenly starts
singing to me and teaching me life
lessons that's it Danielle Radford is a
woman who doesn't want to learn life
lessons this is an amazing beautiful
huge swanky house how Rudnik look you
got you got plenty of room you'll forget
that you were kidnapped that's fine and
at the end of the day he may or may not
turn into Dan Stevens who is a very
handsome man and you know what if you're
dated dudes before maybe the Beast is
kind of interested maybe that's new
maybe you're into it I'm not judging
okay no judgment there Danielle rebuttal
um amphibian man he was lived in a cold
place but he had a big warm heart
whereas the Beast was made into a beast
because he's like a really grow
not good person good people don't kidnap
people's dime ten second rebuttal
people don't get in relationships with
people because they're nice they get
into relationships because they're very
handsome they have nice coats and
lumières dope and they have a really
nice house and that's what I want I'm
tired of working I just want to lay in
that library and just be fed Wow
did not know Joe is so superficial okay
Joe
strong arguments Dan give us some
thoughts start with you how you haven't
even gotten away in an alter sure thank
you
well Joe made an excellent point that
that it's a beautiful house with you
know all sorts of amenities but then
Danielle had the point that you're gonna
be just a prisoner there you can't leave
and yeah for that reason because you're
just a prisoner in that home I'm gonna
give point Danielle different values
different values let's switch it up and
go with Roxy Danielle wasn't gonna be a
prisoner but she was also willing to
keep an phibian man in the tube as her
prisoner and not let him free I think
that this one it was close but Joe
described his best life and the fact
that I felt like he was living a happier
life this point goes to Joe for me you
know and I would never stop you from
living your best life just that's why
we're locked up at one one and my
attempt to weasel out of answering this
doesn't work now I'm even worse position
where I have to decide the ultimate
winner yeah I think that you both
described two different kinds of love he
wants to be pampered and taken care of
Danielle I think though is looking for
true love and for me true love won the
day so I'm gonna vote for Danielle dad a
lot about everybody today oh I think two
different kinds of love should be the
name of the slash fiction that you guys
eventually read
Danielle you take the point it is now
three to Danielle all right going into
question if Danielle takes this she is
today's movie fights winner Joe okay
this is a must win on the ropes must win
point that's a great moment in sports
sitting okay who should win the director
who should win the Oscar for Best
Director 2017 okay we have Gillespie
verse Villeneuve really knew 20 seconds
on the clock for Danielle Radford Europe
um one of the things that worked about I
Tonya which is something that Joe really
touched on was the way that it took
someone who is a very famous villainous
real-life character and it turned her
into somebody who was ultimately
incredibly incredibly sympathetic it
managed to take it managed to take
something as serious as domestic abuse
and while some people complain that they
made that to time Joe star domestic
abuse is no laughing matter Danielle
look this year recently at the awards
were starting to see genre films get
their due and I think Blade Runner 2049
is really leading that pack it's it's
beautifully shot it's beautifully
realized no one asked for a Blade Runner
movie Plus important-sounding people
should get Academy Awards and Villeneuve
is a very important sounding name like I
can just see that Oscar being read out
loud but it just makes sense to me time
okay ten second rebuttal for Craig
Gillespie I believe that one of the
strengths of AI tanya is in the
storytelling in the way that he did the
quick cuts while also acknowledging the
inconsistencies between everyone's story
no so Gillespie is a funnier name
because it's got all those really strong
funny sounds
jost are 10 seconds I disagree cuz I'm
American and belanov is hard to say so
that's funny for me look 20 2014 ein was
just beautifully put together and paste
it is a smart man sci fi smart lady
sci-fi you don't get that that often
into rhyme
okay wow what a battle
dan what are your thoughts I think that
Villeneuve does sound more important me
III guess Joe has the the edge there but
I thought Daniel made a better case for
the movie and what the work that was
done inside the movie rather than the
importance of the name and I don't I
felt like it was more about the work
with her choice with I Tanya so I I side
with Daniella BAM one Oh Danielle Roxy
stryer what do you got
it's so weird what it comes down to in
these feed rounds like really then the
sound of a name that's what you guys
pulled out for today we are the very
serious movie fighters okay you know I I
don't have an opinion on whose name is
more proper for the Oscars so I'm gonna
go to that points that you made about
characters having them be sympathetic or
how its shot that it's shot beautifully
I feel like the person who got a little
more about what the director's job was
was Danielle Danielle get the point for
me Danielle gets the point
Danielle gets the win what a matchup you
two I mean a joy to watch Danielle
congratulations Joe oops I'm gonna I
knew I didn't it is a fun name to say
Danny Villeneuve Danielle let's talk to
you first
congrats again give us give us a plug
where can people find you oh well you
guys can find me here look a whole bunch
and I'll tell you when I'm here also
every Thursday my wrestling podcast
tights and fights comes out on the max
fun Network you can also find me on
hyper RPG on roguelike which is like a
crazy RPG that keeps like changing what
it is like made RPG character might
change it's nothing but chaos and they
basically made that just because I
always mess up games and that's on hyper
RPG on Twitch at
six or six Pacific Standard Time on
Fridays find me on twitter at daniel
Radford go to my comedy shows don't make
it weird
okay bye damn bro plugs Jost are happy
to be here yelling at one of my good
good comedy friends I'm here
no no a lot of bugs I'm here like every
day is there I've been gone for a little
bit but usually I'm here I've got a
comedy album called heroic effort you
can buy it for a dollar at VanCamp calm
but still funny still holds up I gotta
do some work I'm slacking I'm making a
new one I'm really glad I love working
with this group of people and I'm really
glad that in this new year we sort of
get a chance to stretch our wings and
fly a little bit and do what we want to
do and how we want to do it and yeah
Twitter cuz he recently just plugged
something that he did for Devastator
press called legdrop magazine what's it
like a buck or something like that yeah
it's like a dollar yeah it's like a
little it's a zine it's you know my
working you can get a PDF it's really
funny making fun of oh it's cool
wrestling magazines nice my favorite
things awesome and Dan Merle's say hi
and bye to everybody what do you want to
plug hi and bye everybody
screen junkies yes Dan thank you for
holding it down with the facts and
figures today thank you for watching
everybody
heck yeah Roxy in the words of luck Yeti
Joe may have lost but he gave us hashtag
but cam so you'll always have that Joe
I'm Roxy sorry you can find me
everywhere at Roxy stryer and that's
where I will tell you what I'm doing
thanks Roxy the butt cam is a gift to
humanity hashtag bite cam I'm Hal
Rudnick yeah hey follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at Hal Rudnick and I want
to thank everybody for watching movie
fights what a good time you guys bye-bye